.
SPEAKER:  Hello.
SPEAKER:  Hello, friends.  Hi,
welcome boys and girls, ladies
and gentlemen.  Welcome to the
grand opening at the young
Readers Center.  We have
excitement.  We have Batman in
the house.  We have Harry
Potter.  This is an exciting
time.  We are live from the
Library of Congress right in
Washington, D.C. in the
Jefferson building in the young
Readers Center but but what but
what is
so exciting is that we are here
on a Saturday morning.  This is
the first time that the young
Leaders Center in the Library of
Congress, we're going to have
more people coming from the
phones ringing.  We have got a
live author here a book.  We
have teenagers with their
outfits on.  For the first time
ever that this young Leader
Center has been open on
Saturday.  We are also live
streaming.  I think that's what
it's called.  Live streaming to
four cities and we practice
saying hello to you guys in four
cities.
Richmond, New York, Cambridge
and South Carolina.
And the orange county library
Chikawa branch in Orlando,
Florida.  And the Princeton
Public Library in Princeton, New
Jersey.  Hey Princeton.  And
last but certainly not least,
the St. Agnus Library Branch on
Amsterdam Avenue in New York
City.  Yay.  All right.  Now,
this was so exciting.  They had
to write down everything that
I'm supposed to say.  So if you
are watching on YouTube and we
are on YouTube, on YouTube, you
can Tweet us your questions
using #CelebrateYoungReaders.
Everybody got that?
#CelebrateYoungReaders well.
Throughout the day, all day on
Saturday, I mean this is
something on Saturday.  We are
going to have all kinds of
things.  And some of you have
already been doing things,
making book marks.  And we have
got shoes that are lighting up.
Put your foot up.  I might have
to take a nap nap after
this.  I know.  We might all
have to take a nap.  We're going
to have snacks.  It's going to
be good.
It's just good.  I mentioned
though that to start us off we
have a special guest, an award
winning author, Ms. Meg Medina.
[Applause].  And she is going to
talk about her new book in
English and Spanish and she is
going to take us in.  I'm going
to forward over to Ms. Meg.
Take it away.
SPEAKER:  Well, good morning,
everybody.  Buenos dias.  A
couple of things before we we
start we start reading.
Because we have to --
we're in the library, so we're
going to have a story time, all
of us together.  But first I
want to say how exciting it is
to be at the Library of Congress
in a room especially for young
people with our brand new and
wonderful Librarian of Congress
Dr. Carla Hayden.  Thank you
for making the library a
welcoming place for everybody.
SPEAKER:  Don't forget now,
those people in the back.
SPEAKER:  All those adults back
there.  They are always a
problem, the adults.
SPEAKER:  I want to give a shout
out because some of you know my
work and I write for kids in
6 and 7 and I also write for
kids that are 10, 11, 12, 13,
14, 15 and 16.  Just this month
a book came out called "Flying
Lessons And Other Stories" and
it's for kids in elementary.
It's a collection of stories
written by kids from all
different backgrounds.  I have
two special friends friends that
came to the library and they
are all ready to tell you about
the book.  One is EllenEllen Owe
who is back there.
Please make sure that you talk
to Ms.
Ellen about the book and all
other fascinating people.
Next to Ellen is my other good
friend, Lamar
Jiles and he will be the editor
of the next book in that series,
instead of middle grade
stories, it's it's going
to be YA stories, meaning
stories for teens.  So be on the
look out for "Flying Lessons
And Other Stories" but we have
business to tend to this morning
my friends.  Raise your hand if
you have a grandma or grandpa?
Raise your hand if you have an
abuela or abuelo.  Yes, I did
too.  And here is what I
remember about that experience.
That when I was 5, do I have
anybody who is 5 here -- do this
if you are 5?  Okay.  When I
was 5, my abuela came to live
with us.  My abuela and my tia,
they came from Cuba and I hadn't
met them before.  And I was
very worried about them.  So all
these years later when I grew
up, I decided, you know what,
I'm going to write a story about
a girl and her grandmother, her
abuela and they're going to
have a very special problem that
my grandmother and I sort of
had, and that's it, that abuela
spoke Spanish really well and
really quickly and it sounded to
me like this, blah blah blah.
And
I spoke English really well and
really quickly and it sounded
to her like this, blah blah
blah.
And when we met each other and
we wanted to be friends, we were
like
uh-oh.  I wrote a book.
Here is the deal with this book.
Right now I speak Spanish and
English.  So I'm going to read
the book both ways and on this
screen you're going to have the
pictures and you're going to
have the words in English.  And
And in And in my
lap, I have the book in
espanol.  So we're going to have
to be patient which is a really
good quality when we're talking
about people who speak other
languages.  So when I'm reading
in English, the folks who are
live streaming, watching the
live stream, listening to this
wanting to hear it in Spanish.
They're going to wait really
patiently and when I finish
English and go to Spanish,
you're going to wait really
patiently and look at the
pictures drawn by my friend
Angela
Dominguez. Dominguez.  Are you
ready?  I need a person with a
long arm.
Gracias.  Thank you.
So this will be a trick.  I
never done it this way.
Remember the word patience.
What happened?  I hit the end,
I'm going backward.  Hold on,
I'm going all of the way
backward, backward.  There we
go.  "Mango, Abuela and Me" by
Meg Medina.  She comes to us in
winter, leaving behind her sunny
house that rested between two
snakey rivers.  Her old place
was too much for just one as
mommy tells me, as we make room
in my dresser for her clothes
and too far away for us to talk.
Abuela belongs with us now, but
I still feel shy when I meet
this far away grandmother.
[Speaking
Spanish].
Flies it right next to mine.
You get to know each other she
says.  When I show abuela my new
book, she cannot see the
English words.
We can watch the pictures.  But
just before we turn out the
light, she pulls out two things
tucked inside the satin pocket
of her
suitcase, a feather.
From a wild parrot that stood in
her mango trees and a snapshot
of a young man with papi's
smile.  Abuelo she she says
climbing into bed, snuggled
with flowers and sugar in her
hair and sugar and cinnamon
baking in her skin and then I
dream of a red bird circling the
sky.  [Speaking
Spanish].  The rest of the
winter while winter while mami
and papi are at work, abuela
waits for me to get home from
school.  We then bundle up in
thick socks and sweaters to toss
bread to to the to the
sparrows.  Not good enough to
tell abuela the things she
should know like how I am very
good in art and I can run as
fast as the boys.  [Speaking
Spanish].  And her English to
tell me the stories about all I
want to know about abuela and
the rivers that ran right
outside their door, with our
mouths as empty as our bread
baskets, we walked back tomorrow
and watched TV.  [Speaking
Spanish].  Abuela and I cannot
understand each other I
whispered to mommy.  Oh, things
will get matter mommy says.
Remember how it was with Kim?
Kim is my very best friend
at school.  When she was new,
our whole class had to help
teacher English words.  And now
sometimes has to say, please be
quiet girls.  Others are
working.  Sound familiar?
[Speaking Spanish]
after the next day, while
abuela and I are making meat
pies for our snack, I pretend
that I am Ms.
to the ball.  Abuela says dough?
Masa?  And roles it flat.  Masa
I
say.  She drops in place.
Carne, carne.  I say meat.
I'm going to skip in espanol
because you get it.  And then I
remember the word cards we taped
in our classroom to help Kim.
Kim.
So
while abuela fries our
empanadas I put word cards
until everything is covered.
Soon we are playing over here
and say or around the house.
She still calls my pillow a
pallow and says Edward and a
monster.
[Speaking Spanish]
sorry, but the next day I
cannot practice with abuela
after all.  Edmond has run out
of his favorite seed.  So mommy
and I have to ride the bus
downtown to get more.  Sometimes
there kittens in the pet shop
window, but when we arrive,
something even better is behind
the class.  [Speaking
Spanish].  Look I say, the
window has become a jungle
filled with birds and right in
the middle is a parrot at us
with black bead eyes.  I press
my nose to the glass thinking of
the feather abuela gave me.
Let's buy him I tell mommy.  But
you already have Edmond mommy
says.  But I say no, it's not
for me.  It's for abuela.  Like
the parrot that lived in the
mango trees, he can keep her
company while I'm in school.
[Speaking Spanish].
When we bring him home, to
abuela, she she  she says
oh, look a parrot.  And we
named him mango because his
wings are green and orange and
gold like the fruit.  During the
day, abuela teaches him kisses
and bobs his head when she sings
to him.  Mango, abuela says
opening the door when I get home
from school.  Good afternoon I
say and give him a seed.  Mango
calls to me even before we open
the cage.  Buenos tardes.  When
I open the door, he says good
afternoon.  [Speaking
Spanish].
Abuela, Mango and I practice new
words every day in espanol and
it's faster and faster and
abuela and Mango learn the days
of the week, the coins, how do
they learn all
that
is asked what abuela can do.
Give a piece of banana.  She
says --
[speaking Spanish]
beforelong, abuela asks me how
to say harder things too so she
can talk to the neighbors that
stop by.
Come today.  It is chilly today.
Can I get you some cookies and
lemonade?  Soon when
friends stop by to see Mango's
latest tricks, they can
understand everything that
abuela says.
[Speaking Spanish].
It is chilly today.  Can I get
you some cookies It is chilly
today.  Can I get you some
cookies and lemonade?
[Speaking Spanish].
But best of all, now when
abuela and I are lying next to
each other in our beds, our
mouths are full of things to
say.  I tell her about my
buendia and show her Mango and
abuela reads my book only with
little help and she tells me
stories about abuelo who can die
fromdie from riverdie from
river stones
with a single breath.  I draw
pictures for her.  She misses
their old house she says, but
now only a little bit.
[Speaking Spanish].
Mango listens to us from his
porch until my eyes grow heavy.
I say abuela kisses me good
night mia.  Good night Mango
calls and soon we fall asleep.
[Speaking
Spanish].  [Applause]..
SPEAKER:  Do you think it would
be nice for the library to have
a Mango right here?  I like
Edmond.  I like Edmond on that
wheel too, that poor little
gangster hamster.  Do you have
any questions?  We have
questions from our friends all
over the country.  So we're
going to start asking, anybody
have a question?  Like was
Edmond really a hamster or a
ganggangster?  A gangster
hamster.
SPEAKER:  If anybody has had a
hamster, they know they are
gangsters.  They try to get out
of the cage and steal the seeds
and stuff them in the cage.
SPEAKER:  How about we start off
with one of our friends tuning
in today.  We will start off
with Colombia, South Carolina.
We have Jayla asking Meg Medina,
was it hard to learn English
and Spanish?  Spanish?
Spanish?
SPEAKER:
Hi, Jayla.  Thank you for
asking that question.  It wasn't
for me because when I was
little, my mother spoke to me at
home in Spanish.  And I spent
all day in school speaking
English.  And so I learned from
the time that I was very little,
that speaking two languages was
just having more words.  And so
the only confusing part that
happens still sometimes now, is
that there are some things that
you can really say well in
English or really say well in
Spanish, that doesn't have a
good translation in the other
language.  Like for example,
I'll give you this one.  In
Spanish, in Cuban in particular
if they say, boy that's crazy.
They say -- [speaking Spanish]
-- which means that you throw
the Mango really far.  Can you
imagine if I went around saying
boy, you got to throw the Mango
a little far my friends.  I
think my American friends would
say she is loco in the coco.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  Why do people
get Mango?
SPEAKER:  Why do people get
Mango in the story?  I think she
wanted to make her grandmother
feel better about missing her
house.  Sometimes when we move
to a new place we miss our old
place.  Raise your hand if you
ever had to move from one place
to another.  Yeah.  That can be
scary.  And you want to remember
the good things that the place
that you came from.  So I think
Mango was a help er
to help them talk to each other
but also a helper to make
abuela feel at home.  That's
something that we can do when we
have new people come to our
classrooms, new people come to
our neighborhoods, new people
come to our family.  We want to
make them feel
loved and safe.
We have a question from other
one of our friends.  This friend
is named Emily, she is 9 and
she has a question from orange
County Library System in Orlando
Friday.  This is for Dr.
Hayden, what what does what does
the
librarian do?
[Laughter].  She is back folks.
SPEAKER:  Well, I'm so glad that
you asked, Emily.  I was born
in Florida, Tallahassee, hey.
And I know about moving.  And
what a librarian gets to do is
have fun like today when you can
do things and show people what
fun reading is, and meet authors
like Ms. Medina and you get to
pick books for other people to
read and I get to have excuses
to read.  It is one of the best
things you can do I think but
being a librarian is all about
meeting and letting people find
out about things and helping
them find out about things.  So
it's a pretty cool job.
SPEAKER:  Do you know if it I
wasn't a writer and I also was
not a dancer in my next life, I
would like to come back dancing,
I would love to be a librarian
because my librarian, even now
-- maybe this happens to you, do
you go to the library sometimes
and you don't know what to
read?
It I
go to the expert.  And I say
what's new, what is good?
And they always give me the best
advice and the other thing that
I love about librarians is that
it's like they're opening a
magic door for me to walk
through.  And experience the
story.  So I'm so glad that
you're a librarian and there are
so many good librarians out
there.  Thank you librarians.
[Applause].
of
SPEAKER:  Librarians are wizards
of words, like Harry Potter.
It's just a joy.  We have more
questions.
SPEAKER:  We have questions
streaming in today from Maddy, 6
years old and she is in
Princeton.  Maddy says I read
every day, do you?
SPEAKER:  Yes.
SPEAKER:  I'm never not reading.
I would love it, love it.  In
fact, when I don't read, I don't
feel well.  Does that happen to
you?
SPEAKER:  When I'm really really
tired, I can tell I'm really
really tired because I can't
read.  And that's when I know I
need to take that nap, I need to
do something because I love to
read.  Well can I tell you one
of my favorite places to read?
In bed.
SPEAKER:  Me too.
SPEAKER:  It's the best thing.
And sometimes I wake up and
there are books and magazines
and stuff in the bed with me.
And it's so cool.
SPEAKER:  You know, I had a
neighbor once, her name was Liz
and she had three little kids
and one of her daughters, I
remembered that young woman is
in her 20s now but as a little
girl, she can only go to sleep
if her bed was filled with books
and she read until the moments
her eyed dropped and she would
wake up in the morning touching
those books. I think her name
was Kate if I'm not mistaken.  I
will always remember that.  I
I read in I read in
bed, too.  It's such a comfort.
I like going to sleep with my
imagination.
SPEAKER:  Sometimes it's better
than a movie because the movie
is in your head and you can make
up whatever you want.  So So
it's
really kind of cool.  Another
question?  Oh, right here.
You can just stay stuff, too.
speak Spanish in the book?
SPEAKER:  Why did she want to
learn to speak Spanish?  She
wanted to be able to talk to her
grandma.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  I mean why did
you decide to do the book in
Spanish?
SPEAKER:  Oh, my.  A question.
SPEAKER:  That's right.  She got
the story.
SPEAKER:  Thank you for that
clarification.  Well, thank you
very much.  That's a really good
question.  And here is why.
Because I think that there are a
lot of kids in the U.S. who
speak English and Spanish and
lots of families where some of
the people speak English and
some of the people speak Spanish
and I like to give them books
where no matter what language
they're most comfortable in,
they can come together around
the story.  The hard part, when
I'm reading, is waiting.  Right?
It's hard to be patient.  And
And  And that's
true when we're reading books
in true formats.  It's true when
someone is new to English and
they're trying to talk to you
and you're listening really
carefully and trying to be
patient.  But they're trying to
tell you their story.  Even if
it's a sentence, that they want
to tell you.  So it's, for me, I
like including everybody that I
can in the story.  Good answer?
[Laughter].
SPEAKER:  We have a question
over here.
SPEAKER:  And we need more
stories in other languages, too.
SPEAKER:  Go ahead and ask your
question.
give it to the grandma?
SPEAKER:  Say that question one
more time.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  Why did they
give a hamster to the grandma?
SPEAKER:  Why was there a ham
hamster in the story?  Well I'm
not doing well with interpreting
the questions.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  Why did she
give it to grandma?
SPEAKER:  Well, she already had
Edmond.  She already owned him.
Edmond was her pet.  So she
wanted to add Mango the parrot.
She didn't add Edmond.  Edmond
was already hers.  Do you have a
pet?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  Yeah.
SPEAKER:  What do you have?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  A dog.
SPEAKER:  Me too.  What is your
dog's name?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  Onnix.
SPEAKER:  My dog's name is Hugo
and he is a big black Shaggy
dog.  What does your dog look
like?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  He is black
and he has light brown feet.
SPEAKER:  He must be beautiful
and I like that name, Oxxin.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  Well just like
her dog, her dog's name is
Onnix and my dog's name is
Donnix.
SPEAKER:  And we got one
question over
here?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  Why did you
read two books?
SPEAKER:  Why did I?  I think
because I can't not do it.  When
I don't write, I don't feel
very well.  So I love to write
stories.  When I was little, I
loved to hear stories.  And as
an adult, I still like to hear
stories and I like to read
stories but now I like to write
them also.  Do you like to write
stories?  Yes.  So you know
what happens to people like you?
You become people like me or
people like Dr. Hayden.  Book
lovers.
We become librarians and
authors.  If you like to draw
the pictures, we can become
illustrators, the person who
draws in the story.  So there is
lots of stuff for book-loving
people.
SPEAKER:  Batman, yes?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  Why is grandma
in the story?
SPEAKER:  Why did I write a
story with story with a
grandma in it?  I like
grandmas.  I think grandmas and
grandpas and aunts and uncles, I
think family is really
important.  So I love to write
stories where we get to see
people's families.  And there
are all types of families too.
That's what I have learned.
There are all kinds of families
and it doesn't matter.  And it's
really cool to have all types
of people in the family.  I had
a rabbit in the family.
Everybody can be in the family.
SPEAKER:  We have another
question.  This is a question
from Zeekie who is 7 years old
and in Orange County Public
System in Orlando Orlando
Orlando Florida.
How many books are in your
library?
SPEAKER:  I know that one.  And
there are -- think about this.
That's why we are so excited
that you're going to be here
more and more and more.  32
million books.
Just books.  And there are -- I
even -- it's so much to even
say how much.  100 million other
things.  Comic books, games,
all types of
photos.  Everything.  That's a
lot of stuff, isn't it?
SPEAKER:  Thank goodness you
have it.  Because when I write
books, I come to the library to
do research. So I came to this
library, the Library of
Congress, when I was writing --
I have a novel called "Burn Baby
Burn" for teenagers and I came
right across the street and
spent a lot of time doing
research here.  And the other
thing that I don't know that
they can see, but maybe maybe
they
can do a virtual tour on the
website.
SPEAKER:  We are working on
that.
SPEAKER:  To see how beautiful
the Library of Congress is.
It's two buildings.  We're in
the Jefferson building.  There
is the Madison building.
SPEAKER:  There are three
buildings right around here.
There is another one.  You got
to go to that one too.
SPEAKER:  On the side.  Yeah,
there are three.  But I knew
there were two.  The Jefferson
building, you just shouldn't
miss it.  And you should go up
and just look at how beautiful a
monument it is for books, and
knowing and thinking and
learning.  And that really
matters.
SPEAKER:  And the cool thing is
that it's your library.  This is
everybody's
library.  So Florida and New
Jersey and New York, this is
your library too.  And I am very
glad you said you said about
the virtual tour, because very
soon, you will be able to take a
tour of all three buildings.
And there is even another one in
Virginia.  All three buildings
you'll be able to look and it's
3D.  Wherever you are, you can
tour the building.
SPEAKER:  Yeah.
SPEAKER:  Great.  Now oh, look,
we must be having too much fun.
Because now the adults want to
ask questions.
SPEAKER:  They want to get in on
the action.  There you go.  He
is going to ask a question.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  What was
President Jefferson's
involvement in establishing the
library?
SPEAKER:  Wow, now you you can
tell that was an adult
question.
[Laughter].
SPEAKER:  And I'm so glad it's
yours.
SPEAKER:  And I happen to know
that one, too.  Because what
this gentleman wanted to know is
why is this even called -- the
building that we're in now is
the Thomas Jefferson building.
And he says what was -- how was
Thomas Jefferson, he was the
president a long time ago.
Very, very important president.
Because he thought about a lot
of things when the country was
getting started.  And one of the
things he says was, this is a
new country.  It was 1796 way
back.  He said you know what a
new country needs?  It needs a
library.  And he made sure that
books from his library were
given to the country so we can
have this wonderful thing now.
So thank you for asking that and
thank you Thomas Jefferson.  We
have got another one.
SPEAKER:  We do.  This one is
from New York.
SPEAKER:  Other New York City.
Amsterdam Avenue.
SPEAKER:  Queens, New York.
SPEAKER:  That's Jamaica, New
York.
SPEAKER:  They actually want to
know if you miss living in
Queens and the real question is,
Jessica wants to know, is there
a difference between how you
write chapter books and picture
books?
SPEAKER:  Oh.
SPEAKER:  And I am from Queens.
Flushing, Queens.
SPEAKER:  Flushing.
SPEAKER:  Flushing, Queens is
where I'mwhere I'm
from. There is a difference when
you write every type of book.
You have to think about who is
reading the book and how long
the book can be and how many
words that reader has to be able
to unlock your story.
Is somebody going to be reading
the book with them or are they
going to be reading it by
themselves?  There are all
things that I have to do with --
the
the first
the first thing
I ask myself, what story do I
want to tell?
The second thing is who am I
telling it to?  And the third
thing is, what is the best way
to tell that story to that
person?  So I have to match
those three things up.
Sometimes I make a mistake and I
try it in one one way one way
and
I go, no, no, it doesn't make
sense this way.  It's much
better as a novel or as I
picture book or whatever.  But
those three things, in some way,
have to line up.
SPEAKER:  Wow, that takes a lot
of thought.
SPEAKER:  It does.  It's a brain
buster.
SPEAKER:  It looks so wonderful
and everything.  Wait a minute,
is there a medal on that book?
SPEAKER:  There is a medal on
that book, my friends.
SPEAKER:  Can you tell us,
whenever you see this kind of of
of medal
on a book, that means that it
won a prize.  So can you tell us
about the prize?
SPEAKER:  I can.  And I'm glad I
can tell you this with the
question from New York.  Because
this book won a prize called
the Fuda Honor Award.  An honor
for writing and illustration.
And I was not the illustrator.
The illustrator is a wonderful
woman named Angela Dominguez who
is a writer and illustrates her
own  book.
So find her stuff.  Was a
librarian, the first Latina in
Harlem in the 20s.
SPEAKER:  Yes, 1920.
SPEAKER:  Yeah.  And she looked
out at her students and she
looked at them and looked at the
kids who were in the pages of
the books in her library and she
said, wait a minute, this
doesn't exactly match.  We need
more stories and more books that
have all kinds of people in
them.  So she dedicated her
whole life to diversifying,whole
life to diversifying, to create
getting stories and books that
reflect all people.
And so when the book comes out
every yearbooks publish, there
is a committee, and they read
and read and read and they are
looking for books and celebrate
Latino life and experience in
the United States.  And they
pick a winner for illustration,
and they pick a winner for
writing.  And I'm so proud that
this book got that last year,
not this year, but last year.
So, thank you for asking
SPEAKER:  And I remember when I
was 7 years old in Jamaica
Queens and there was a little
story front library right across
from my school, P. S. 96 and I
ran in and a librarian gave me a
book called "bright April".  I
loved that book so much.  I got
library fines.  You know what
why I loved it?  There was a
little girl who was 8 years old
and looked just like me.  Brown
pigtails and I looked in the
book and saw myself.  And I
said, it must be pretty good if
I can see myself.  And it meant
a lot to me to just have that.
And I hugged that book and I
hugged that book.  And I love
that book to this day.  I see
myself in something that I love.
SPEAKER:  I love that you are
from Jamaica Queens.  I went to
P. S. 22.
SPEAKER:  I went to P. S. 96.
In New York, means public
school.  That means so much to
me.  I was already looking at
books to find out about other
people and I loved books and I
loved reading but I never saw
myself in a book.  It means a
lot.  Any other questions?
SPEAKER:  The next question is
going to be the last question.
SPEAKER:  Okay.  Two questions
-- okay, three last questions.
SPEAKER:  Three super fast last
questions.  questions.
questions.
SPEAKER:
Here is the first one right
right here.
little, did you have to read and
write a lot?
SPEAKER:  Yes.  To become an
author, yes.  You really can be
anything.  It pays to read and
write a lot.  And it's also
super fun.  So you you really
you really don't
mind doing it.  But yes, you
have to be a good reader.
SPEAKER:  And then we have
another person -- a teenager.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  All
right, so like I'm an artist.
Yeah, and I consider writing to
be like an art.  So when I'm
doing my thing, I make music and
paint and stuff.  So when I'm
doing my stuff, I feel like it
comes best when I'm a
vessel and it pours out of me
and it's spontaneous.
What is your method?
SPEAKER:  I love that you have
all kinds of art at your
disposal.  As an artist, there
is a whole time period where
it's just coming out of you.
For me, it's where it will be a
sentence that I write down
somewhere or a photograph that I
see somewhere and I cut out and
I hold onto.  When I wrote the
book "Ayesha Wants a Car" for
a long time, the sentence kept
coming up tocoming up to
me.  Wants a car.
Wants a car.  Did buy the first
family car.  And for some
reason, the sentence kept
jamming in my head.  You
probably have the same thing, a
phrase that you can't get rid of
it then it becomes something.
The important thing is that you
follow it.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  Right.
SPEAKER:  Just follow it.  But
thank you so much for your
question.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  It's
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  It's great to
be here.
SPEAKER:  Isn't this cool to
have create and write and all of
that?  And we're going to have
more and more of this on
Saturdays.  Let's give a hand
for Saturdays.  [Applause].
Saturdays are good days.  And
it's a time when you can do
things.  So we're going to
actually do something really
fun.  We have one more question
from our friends and we're going
to answer it before we go.
Because we have a special ribbon
cutting.  We're going to cut
the ribbon to this room to say,
it's open on Saturdays.  Come
and everything.  We have
visitors that are this big.  We
have two teenagers from our
advisory board.  We also want
you to know that we want you to
come back and tell us, what
other things would you like to
see in this childrens' center
and youth center.  We're going
to be getting a lot of ideas
from people.  We hope that we
can have more authors like Ms.
Medina to talk to you wherever
you are on a regular basis.
That would be good.  We have one
more question from?
SPEAKER:  Princeton.
SPEAKER:  Princeton, New Jersey.
SPEAKER:  9 years old.  What is
your next book?
SPEAKER:  The next book, the
main character lives in Florida
which her mother and father and
grandmother and grandfather and
tia and two really pesky twins,
Leo and Tomas and everybody is
just in her affairs.  And she is
12.  And she is going to a new
school.  And at the same time
she is noticing some things
changing with her friends,
changing with her grandfather,
changing with herself.  That's
as much as I got.  [Laughter].
Stay tuned.
SPEAKER:  Stay tuned.  Thank you
Ms. Medina, we just can't thank
you enough.  [Applause].  We're
going to cut the ribbon.
And we are going to look -- I
would like to have our two
helpers come up.  We have -- I
mentioned we have an advisory
board here.
And all of you are going to be
helping helping us.
From the Richard Wright Public
Charter School here in
Washington.  An 11th grader,
Veronica
Payne and Edward Tolson.
Everywhere you are, we're going
to need some help.  So who wants
to help hold the ribbon?  Come
on.
Hold the ribbon.  Okay.  We
have got all of the cameras and
we're going to do this.  And
then we're going to count down.
Where are the big scissors?
Have you ever seen scissors this
big?  Wow.
These are big scissors.  Now we
got to be careful though.  You
got to be careful anyway.  So
when you have super big
scissors, okay, so we're going
to have someone help us.  You
going to help?  Okay.  Now watch
Batman.  Okay.  Be careful.
Count down everybody.
SPEAKER:  5, 4, 3, 2, 1.  Go.
[Applause].
11th graders are
going to say something.  You
guys were really good at this
ribbon cutting.
SPEAKER:  It's the scissors.
SPEAKER:  The scissors were
good.  Who is going to speak
first?  Veronica is going to
speak.
SPEAKER:  Good morning,
everyone.  How are ya'll today?
Okay.  Well, my name is
Veronica, I attend Richard
Wright Charter School and I'm
part of the team building
program here at the Library of
Congress.  [Applause].  First I
want to start off with how great
I think this program is.  Ms.
Kathy and the other staff work
really hard to make sure that we
are comfortable and engaged in
the discussions we have at each
meeting.  If I wasn't already a
book lover, I would spend the
the  the day
with Ms. Kathy because her love
for books is inspiring.
Because of this program, I learn
of new authors, read some
pretty amazing books and enjoy
some good snacks.  I never left
our meetings without learning
new things, whether it be about
books or other students in the
program.  That's what I like
about the teen board program.  I
am surrounded by people who may
not be familiar but enjoy books
just as much as I do.  This
program is a place where young
people can freely express
themselves, reading, writing and
talking about books without
judgment.  That's why I'm
thankful for the Teen Board
program and thankful for the
experience and experience and
everything experience and
everything that I
have learned from it.
[Applause].
SPEAKER:  Good morning everyone.
My name is Edward
Tolson.  I'm 15 years old.  The
Teen Board is where I can
express myself through
literature.  I have been a part
of the young Leaders Center that
keeps getting better with the
books that are available.  My
first question when I joined the
program was, was it going to be
the average book club?  In the
Library of Congress, lots of old
books are housed.  However,
that was not the case.  The
young Readers Center is multi
dimensional.  We are exposed to
new books every month and the
authors meet us and tell us how
they started writing and we have
great snacks and wonderful
books from various genres for
our reading pleasure.
I enjoy our monthly meetings
where we discuss our books and
hear what other students read
and enjoying the environment and
culture of the Young Leaders
Center.  It's a great program
for young teenagers everywhere
for their minds and expanding
their lives through reading.
[Applause].
SPEAKER:  Now there is a reason
why we wanted you to hear about
the teen advisory board and how
much fun that is.  The snacks,
you will be getting some snacks
yourself.  And we think -- what
do you think?  How about a kid
board?  Right.  The teens that
have all the fun, we think the
kids should have some too.  So
we want you to think about being
a part on the new kid board.
Give yourself a hand.  I think
you all have good questions.
And to celebrate that and
celebrate Ms. Medina being here
and all of the good stuff.
We're really going to renovate
and fix this stuff up.  We're
going to throw stuff around and
make a mess.  [Applause].  Yeah,
we're just going to make a mess
and have a good time.  Can
somebody tell us how we're going
to do this?  We're just going
to -- you're going to show us?
We're going to count down again
and thank you to all of our
friends, in New Jersey, in New
York, on Amsterdam Avenue,
Florida.  One more, South
Carolina.  Let's say goodbye to
to  to everybody.
Whoa.  Thank you.
We will see you soon and come
help us make a mess.  Come on.
1, 2, 3.  Yay.  [Cheers and
applause].  Thank you.  Now,
let's give some treats.